Hi there!
I’m Mismo.
I’m a sniffer dog
for French Customs.
It’s a cool job:
I get to fight the bad guys
who try to smuggle all sorts of stuff
across the border,
and I have colleagues across the EU
doing the same thing.
Together, we make sure
that illegal things don’t get into Europe.
Sometimes we have to work
in rough conditions,
but actually...
we love it !
People know us because we’re good
at detecting illegal drugs,
explosives and large
amounts of cash.
But we are also trained to find
forbidden food, or ivory.
Oh...hang on...
I think I smell something!
Got to follow
my nose!
Ah ha!
Found it!
Oh, by the way,
let me introduce Newton!
He’s not trained yet, but soon,
he’ll be a great partner
and together, we’ll help
protect the EU borders.
It’s a dog’s life...
and we love it!